he's been compared to Elvis Costello but
I think Huey has a far more bitter
cynical sense of humor is that a
raincoat it is
[Music]
Revenge
he's got some bad ideas
[Music]
Michael Knowles here today I'm going to
be your Alpha Chad guide into the grind
set and how you can become a based Sigma
male what does any of that mean
it's complicated
you've heard of an alpha male and a beta
male you've probably heard of an alpha
male and a beta male because of a 1982
book about chimpanzee politics by a guy
named Franz DeWall based on earlier
research from the 40s about how wolf
packs operate there was an alpha and
then there are the betas who serve the
alpha then you get the chimpanzees of
the 80s and then people start applying
that to Human Society in the mid-2000s
there was a pickup artist named Neil
Strauss who applied it to dating and he
said if you want to pick up chicks you
got to be an alpha male and that
involves performing all sorts of things
and wearing all sorts of silly clothing
and then in 2010 the Blogger Theodore
Beale who goes by The Gnome de plume Vox
day greatly expanded this idea of the
socio-sexual hierarchy of men to include
all sorts of other terms the categories
are alpha we know what that is that's
the leader that's the big hot cool guy
guy who leads the organizations and gets
all the chicks then we get betas in this
new more complex system of male
categorization the betas are the
lieutenants they might be good looking
they get a fair number of girls but they
don't lead the organizations they attach
themselves to an alpha and then they
execute on the Alpha's desires they're
deeply loyal both to the Alpha and the
organization as a whole then after that
you get the Deltas the worker bees the
Deltas are the people who are very
diligent about their tasks They Don't
Really lead anything they're not
necessarily all that loyal but they do
their job and they do it right the
Gammas according to this scheme are the
the angry nerds who might be more
intelligent than average might have more
knowledge in a specific area than most
other people but they're kind of
irritated about it they don't like their
place in the social pecking order and so
they can be resentful of the alphas and
the other people in the line who maybe
get more girls and make more money and
have more social success after that you
get the omegas
the omegas are the losers they're the
School shooters they are just so
divorced from anything resembling normal
society they are completely outcast
and then you get
the sigmas the sigmas are the new object
of Desire women want them men want to be
them the sigmas are outside of the
hierarchy so according to Beale the
sigmas are like the alphas in that
they're courageous and they have vision
and they're probably pretty hot and
women really like them but whereas the
alpha is the head of the wolf pack
these sigmas are lone wolves they don't
have a pack they don't care about the
hierarchy they want to go their own way
so the sigmas seem super cool and
they're associated with all sorts of of
popular movie characters it's the Han
Solo type the Clint Eastwood type
Patrick Bateman from American Psycho Ed
Norton in Fight Club Ryan Gosling in
Blade Runner Ryan Gosling in Drive
what do all of these characters have in
common on The Superficial level they
reject modern society they think that
this whole social structure that we have
it's all Bs they think specifically in
our modern culture that
the wokeness the lies the consumerism
the the shallow relationships that it
all seems sort of artificial they want
to break past it they want to transcend
it they they've been driven a little bit
mad or at the very least frustrated by
the pitfalls of our modern culture we've
all been raised on television to believe
that one day we'd all be millionaires
and movie gods and rock stars but we
won't
slowly learning that fact
we're very very pissed off
the other thing that all these
characters have in common is that they
are complete fantasies but but I mean
even within the logic of these stories
these characters are delusional
especially the two most prominent ones
Patrick Bateman and American Psycho is
delusional by the end of the movie you
realize that Patrick Bateman hasn't
actually done the things that you think
that he has done at Norton in Fight Club
by the end of the movie you realize Ed
Norton's a schizo
it's not real so why is the sigma male
mindset so popular right now why is it
probably the biggest trend on Tick Tock
specifically with with young men ages 17
into their early 20s
two reasons one because Society is so
obviously corrupt and as Society breaks
down and and becomes more transparently
corrupt people are going to want to
break away from that and go their own
way that is perfectly natural totally
understandable
the reason that this idea though is very
popular among this particular group of
men is because that is the time
when life is least settled that time in
your late teens into your early twenties
is when you have left the very
well-defined social structure of school
where achievement is very easy to
measure but then you leave that and none
of that stuff matters anymore
but it's still before the time that
you've ever actually accomplished
anything in your career and so what do
you do you fantasize yes I'm I don't
have real accomplishments to my name
exactly but I I know that I'm capable of
them people just don't understand it I
think this is why Sigma is so much more
attractive to people than Alpha because
the alpha male is measurable he is the
top of an organization he has lots of
people who are loyal to him he can
command respect when he walks into a
room the sigma says that he is like the
alpha but without any of the outward
signs so
he doesn't have a wife
well that's okay he doesn't want one and
he doesn't have an organization that he
leads well that's why he doesn't want
one and he he doesn't really get all of
the accolades usually well that's fine
he doesn't want those accolades he
doesn't care the sigma is holding
Caufield in Catcher in the Rye he is
going to be authentic he doesn't care
about your social structures and all the
rest of it the sigma male description
is the most common feeling especially
for this group of young men and I say
this as a former young man myself and
I'm sure many people can identify with
this
the irony is that according to all the
people who promote this idea of of male
Society
the
Sigma is the rarest type of man
oh very a diamond in the rough very very
few people are really the sigmas and yet
everybody who pays attention to this
stuff
identifies as a sigma or at the very
least desires to be a sigma so we admire
the the idea of the Lone Wolf the man
going his own way but that isn't real
because man is a social creature and is
fundamentally a political creature and a
coupling creature even in the movies the
the man who goes his own way he can't be
held down he won't be bound by any bonds
of Love or Community right Han Solo is
the archetypal version of this in all
but what happens he ends up with
Princess Leia of course because that is
a fantasy and and we might wish to deny
that but we can't we can't ultimately
deny our own nature we
are made for society what do you get I
don't think so when you cross I think a
mental loner with a society
the whole idea of the grind set the
grind set is this idea that you're going
to ignore all these external
distractions and you're just going to
focus on what is important to better
yourself is self-undermine
because if you are spending your time
worrying about whether you're an alpha
or a beta or a sigma or a Lambda or
whatever
you are manifestly not on your grind set
and because if you are in the correct
grind set you would you would be
ignoring all of those distractions
including all of this
this focus on oneself and one's own
personality absent any accomplishment
absent any particular practice of virtue
in trying to improve yourself strictly
through your own will a nichein idea
that in this chaotic senseless Society
we just have to exercise our own will to
improve ourselves Against All Odds and
become the Superman
you you will fail your will is not
sufficient for that your ability is not
sufficient for that this is a fallen
world and so if you if you set out
trying to save yourself you are going to
fail you're you're going to sin you're
going to flop you're going to lose the
girl you're going to lose the job at
some point you're going to lose your
strength at some point and then you're
going to die
even your willpower
I'm not very good at controlling it
anyway
sometimes you hear people say reject
modernity Embrace masculinity it's fine
to reject the evils of the modern world
all the porn and the selfishness and the
wimpiness and all that but embracing
masculinity is not sufficient even the
phrase Embrace tradition that's a lot
closer but you've just got to go deeper
the appeal of this classification of men
is that you're seeing past all the
nonsense forget about all that
idealistic mumbo-jumbo you ever heard
about being a man this is what it's
really about
that vision of man
is no less artificial than the
idealistic version of man knights in
shining armor and
Gallant courtly love and all the rest of
it I'm reminded of the first two stories
of the Canterbury Tales by Jeffrey
Chaucer the Canterbury Tales opens up
with the Knight's Tale which is about
these two gallon Knights who are
fighting over this woman that they saw
through a window and they both fell in
love with her and it's for the absolute
highest ideals and in the end they
sacrifice their own desires for their
love for this woman and for honor and
chivalry and all the rest of it and then
the next Tale in Canterbury Tales is a
retelling of that tale it's the Miller's
Tale But the retelling of that tale is
the most disgusting vulgar lewd kind of
story you've ever read with all sorts of
body parts and bodily functions and a
bunch of cuckolding and deceit it's just
nasty and ugly the way that these
stories are it's often misinterpreted is
that the former is the is the silly
Preposterous idealistic version and the
latter that's the way Human Society
really works but no they're both absurd
it's true that that Human Society
doesn't doesn't operate like a tale of
Courtney Love from the Middle Ages but
likewise it doesn't operate like a like
a farce either I mean for for that story
to hold true it would require such
gullibility from from everybody else
that is not human they're both
caricatures
of what really happens
that's how it starts
the fever the rage the feeling of
powerlessness
the turn is good men
cruel
sex obsessed left-wing narcissists have
gender pronouns
sex-obsessed right-wing narcissists have
this Alpha Beta Gamma Sigma Greek
alphabet
signifier stuff
it's basically the same thing though
ultimately this is just horoscopes for
men you can read yourself into any of
these
you might say well I've got certain
attributes of the alpha male
or uh you're you you've got some aspects
of the beta or the delta
or the even the gamma maybe you've got a
nerdy kind of interest that you know a
lot about some subject
one hopes you're not the Omega
which is the school shooter category and
you might say well I am like the sigma
why are you like the sigma well because
I'm I'm alone sometimes no it means
you're lonely it's true people are
lonely why is this cropping up now
well it's because the whole society
feels alienated
because over the recent decades the
structures that held us together as a
society have broken down you see this in
the collapse of family you see this in
the collapse of local community you see
this in the collapse of national loyalty
and you see this in the rise of
technology which divorces us from our
real communities and and encourages us
to participate in Virtual communities it
it it encourages us actually to deny the
realities of the body and to live ever
more in virtual reality and so people
spend more and more of their time online
but it doesn't satisfy us because we're
not only disembodied spirits and Minds
we're we're bodies as well and and so
people can feel more and more isolated
you don't know your neighbors as well
you don't go out and see people you
don't touch people we just went through
a pandemic lockdown where you weren't
allowed to hug people or really have any
bodily contact whatsoever that can be
very alienating and it can make you feel
like you're the Lone Wolf without a pack
no you're just lonely people are very
very lonely these days
and then you're constantly going down
this Rabbit Hole of what is really
authentic no no my true
personality type my true male category
is not defined by the stuff I do in the
real world it's not defined by the wife
that I do or do not have or the job that
I do or do not perform no it's something
deeper and more esoteric and more
authentic but the notion
that identity is defined by authentic
fixed characteristics divorced from any
expression in the real world is
preposterous
your identity is defined by what you
worship
and then and then by your habits of
virtue advice that follow but from the
objects that you worship
code my shoes my spotless clothes
my face
putting them on I abandon my disguise
became myself
[Music]
man is a mimetic the the word memetic
it relates to the word meme like a meme
actually this whole thing is a meme so
the the the the whole meme phenomenon of
the sigma males and the Alpha and the
beta and the Omega totally underscores
this point the way that we take on our
identities is through imitation
this is an Insight that goes back to the
ancient Greeks re-articulated in recent
years by Renee Gerard the philosopher
it's one that is even pushed forward by
scientists like Richard Dawkins one of
the most famous lines in Fight Club is
that everything's a copy of a copy of a
copy that's true Everything is a copy of
a copy of a copy the fixed Creator the
unmoved Mover of everything that moves
creates the world
after his own image and specifically
creates man after his own image and
likeness this is why man is called the
Imago day the image of God so so
what should we be copying
right now a lot of people seem to think
that we should be copying
Pick Up Artist con man or or fictional
sociopaths from Hollywood movies
probably not a good idea probably if you
want to
be the best man that you can be which is
really what everybody's after with all
of these silly signifiers then you
should copy the ultimate good which
whether whether you consider yourself
Christian or not whether you consider
yourself religious or not I think you
have to at least acknowledge that
Christianity animated the whole
civilization if you value Western
Civilization at all Western Civilization
at its peak you have to grant that that
was a civilization modeled after
Christianity a civilization that was
copying Christ
and Christ Christians believe
embodies all the very best
aspects of all the categories of men all
of the categories not just the alpha or
the sigma or this or that
he embodies the courage and vision and
Leadership of the alpha he embodies the
Loyalty of the beta he embodies the
diligence of the Delta he embodies the
expertise of the gamma even the
suffering of the Omega not the school
shooting but the suffering Christ even
imitates that and then of course the
going One's Own Way of the sigma in as
much as this is a Fallen World the devil
is the prince of this world and so one
must contradict the Fashions of this
world if one is to be truly good you've
never seen a miracle
when people talk about Alphas mostly
they're just talking about people being
big aggressive bullies so that you'll
notice that's not actually how
successful leaders lead whether we're
talking about chimpanzees or whether
we're talking about human beings what
about the recognition that humility is a
virtue Prudence is a virtue
courage prerequisite for all of the
other virtues
we learn through imitation and what we
do in the real world it's not just
divorced from our physical reality it's
performed the more you perform virtues
the easier it will be to do those
virtues and the more virtuous you will
become the more you engage in Vice the
easier it will be to engage in those
vices the harder it will be to stop
engaging in those vices this is the
definition of an addiction and the more
vicious you will become it's it's
practiced it's and and that that does
change your identity you can recognize
that the world is broken and that you we
shouldn't go along with the Fashions of
the day and maybe that gives us a sense
of a kind of ironic kinship with Patrick
Bateman or
The Joker right but do we fall down the
nihilistic navel gazing narcissistic
self-obsessed loser dumb
of the people who who think that the
most important thing in the world is is
contained between their ears and from
the top of their head to their toes or
do we lift our heads up to the heavens
and look something higher and then
model our behavior on that it's the only
way to become all that man is meant to
be in all of his ultimate perfection
might not get it quite on this world but
at least gives us hope and a direction
and a shot to become that man if not
here then in the life of the world to
come
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]